drones they buzz over the skies of Iraq
Pakistan or Yemen unmanned spying
missile launching used to wipe out
suspected militants without trial they
kill non-combatants too and they've
become a deeply controversial American
weapon of war but drones mean something
else entirely in many workshops
throughout America it's an industry
exploding with the potential to do a lot
of good and some things that are more
than a little warrior then give it some
gas they're good beautiful face take
throw that wake up
when you were um you were doing the
right stick forward but you're like just
meet mark kornblatt and his business
partner
Eli Delia these guys are completely
insane no really let's try one more one
more time so it's gonna drift here I'm
just gonna I'm gonna take it all the way
they brought me to their secret test
site an abandoned train depot so I could
see what has been going on in the DIY
workshops of San Francisco
mocking Eli are leaders of a rapidly
growing community of Americans who build
and modify small drones
we mounted a paintball gun on a drone
and so we flew the drone around with a
working gun on it and the operator could
see who was in its target so we were
flying around shooting Eli the paintball
nowhere I could run anywhere so let's
replace paintballs with bullets Lockheed
Martin calls you up tonight and says we
want you guys to work on this new
assassination I think we both just hang
up the phone right we may be advocating
violent games and kind of crash-up Derby
type activities with the drone but we
will be doing that to drive the
technology forward we wrote code that
would fly find faces in the crowd fly up
and take a photograph of a face it would
then upload that image to the Google
image search and if it found a match it
could identify who you were so how are
you not working for the government you
know it took us ten minutes to write
that code if you wanted to use a drone
for nefarious purposes it's just as easy
as using it for good purposes it's all
on the intent of the user if Marc's
right and it's about intent that may be
one of the reasons people don't trust
the cops with drones when the Seattle
police bought a pair with federal
government funds they provoked so much
outrage that they had to send them back
here in Colorado at the Mesa County
Sheriff's Office things are looking less
shaky it's stabilized to make sure that
the cameras always pointed down no
matter how the you know the aircraft is
moving in the wind because the angle so
I'll be honest I expected to meet a
cowboy proud of his drone but UAV
program had been Miller turned out to be
the kind of geek I'd meet in San
Francisco he runs the county's drone
program you guys have never spied on
anyone have you no well you know when we
chase bad guys
that's not surveillance technically
speaking that's a search and rescue
mission it's just that the legal status
of the person that we're looking for is
different from say your lost hiker
photos been showed me how they use their
drones to reconstruct crime scenes
something like a personal Google Earth
pasted together
he says they mainly use their drones
after crimes have been committed not
before so pretend you're the jury I can
take you for a tour of the crime scene
in three dimensions but drones have also
come into play during crime a couple of
guys were at a party they got in a fight
one guy left the other guy chased him
down stabbed him seven times and then
left into the bushes unmanned aircraft
in that case is perfect we put it up
above the bushes and we went looking for
the bad guy we didn't find him that day
but the safety level that we provided to
my guys on the ground it's priceless
we've already seen in the last two years
a lot of departments acquire drones and
sometimes really without any public
scrutiny Palka Higgins of the Electronic
Frontier Foundation says the temptation
for police to use drones for
surveillance will only grow as the
technology improves one technology that
police have been really excited about
using is called the Stingray which
intercept cell phone signals and read
text messages they come through and that
could be put on a drone the e FF has
been working to cast light on law
enforcement agencies with drone programs
and develop legislation to limit their
spying powers five years ten years you
could imagine something like being
algorithmically flagged for suspicion
and having a drone follow you around
Minority Report exactly well there's a
lot of things from Minority Report that
I think we could we could plan to see
where without checks without public
scrutiny without transparency that's the
direction that law enforcement wants to
go given that it's become abundantly
clear that the NSA is going through our
emails listening to our phone calls
spying on individuals both in the United
States and elsewhere in a deep way
what difference does it drove me there's
a concern that you might turn towards
what we call privacy nihilism like well
you know privacy is dead or there's
nothing worth protecting there's a lot
of information that you can gather from
aerial surveillance that isn't obviously
available any other way
there is something unnerving about being
a journalist and knowing if a police
force or government wanted information
about a source or a story I was working
on they could simply fly a drone over my
head and intercept my cell phone signal
the technology is advancing rapidly
driven by a booming industry some
analysts forecast nearly 90 billion
dollars will be spent globally on drones
over the coming decade you're growing
right at an incredible pace this is kind
of our flight Locker this is our arrow
here this is actually a 3d robotics
ready to fly airplane this is a dodeca
copter it's a 12 rotors Colin Gwynn
represents 3d robotics
it's a Bay Area operation that got 35
million dollars from venture capitalists
to get off the ground
they focus on non-military drones and
have sold south to the Tijuana police
force in Mexico but the fact that this
is in the same price range as like a
small personal electronic device pretty
wild the more accessible these machines
become the more people decide ok I can
do that now I can afford that now and I
could sure benefit from being able to
see my role from above Demond from who
literally it's every walk of life it's
the farmer in Kansas it's the hunter in
Texas it's the action sports guy in
Southern California it's your Realtors
about law enforcement talking about you
know law enforcement using drones can be
a very touchy subject you know and can
be a subject of much debate I think that
with any new technology there's going to
be the potential for using them for bad
reasons I think with drones specifically
the good uses of drones are so far
outweigh the potential negative uses
McNiel I have channeled their idealism
about technology into a movement of DIY
drone makers and every flourishing
movement is supported by a community
it's called a game of drones it's all
about testing your drone in combat
it's the drone head
you got 90 seconds to do your work so
you want to go to Z and put the prop
back on okay I need a just pulls on out
of his pocket everybody acts the same
thing is that a throne or who do you
work for are you military just gonna put
together
scrying around there spying on me people
think I'm spying on
this is the Barbie Dream crown
I went from building my drone to now
kind of being the
male crusader female superhero
ow
watching these guys fly five drones at a
time attacking each other smashing into
walls it's a relief to know that
everyone here has good intentions but
imagining these drones in the hands of
people with different motives that's
when it gets dicey and while the US
government has made efforts to regulate
commercial drone use through the Federal
Aviation Authority the question remains
who or what serves as a check on
government use if you've got all these
ingredients rights
we've got facial recognition technology
drones we're one step away from tipping
off into a police state aren't we
we're one step away from tipping off
into Skynet always but it's it's a
matter of time I think there are
authorities that want to use it for
surveillance and stuff like that but
it's up to the public to kind of keep
pushing them back and keep them at bay
it's a strange but compelling traits of
the California tech boom that on this
question even the most critical voices
are optimistic in the short term we may
see things happening without
transparency but hopefully in the longer
term the the long arc of technology
bends towards justice subscribe on
YouTube follow us on Twitter and like us
on Facebook